tha
ouais comme et
m
sami
[Musique]
et chalon
bienvenue en touche pas à mon alors on
m'a demandé de faire la présentation des
chroniques alors je vais commencer au
pour ceux qui croient que partout sans
toit se coiffer et ben c'est pas vrai
elle se maquille aussi
[Applaudissements]
matthieu delormeau voilà on va dire
qu'il a attrapé la chtouille en haricot
vert ne suis pas chroniqueur je suis
animateur à différentes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on continue parce qu'on en direct faux
papiers avec lucas sur les oreilles que
j'en mets dans les coûts d pour terminer
pour terminer celui sans qui encouraient
va faire cette émission en tentant je
préférerais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa quête pour l'indiqué c'est un gâteau
pour voilà je me présente à gâteau si
j'ai une loche forêt de personnes qui
vient me parler expressément et la cause
du sida
merci d'applaudir agathe au front
[Applaudissements]
avec toi bien de méthode et moi les
shows ses valises mais la donne ne
change pas le posera sur toi l'apport du
clause ne retient pas dis-moi dix mots
avec tes doigts sur ma promo
[Musique]
voila voila j'ai pratiqué la voile à
bauchi
recharger des matons et bayal assez bon
iver cm3 4 temps dira
[Musique]